né en 1954 d'un père irlandais et d'une
mère francophone libanaise à montréal a
beaucoup de qualités
6 et parler la langue des affaires et du
show business il ne sait pas parler la
langue d'un canadien sur quatre
le français mais est il trop tard pour
bien faire
kevin o'leary annonçait cette semaine à
la télévision de radio canada cbc qu'il
travaillait avec un tuteur français et
ils s'engageaient à devenir bilingue
mais s'agit-il ici d'une promesse
politicienne
quel nom lui a déjà déclaré qu'il ne lui
semblait pas essentiel de s'exprimer en
français pour comprendre des enjeux du
québec et que de toute façon
citations les québécois de 18 à 35 ans
sont presque tous bilingues
la question du bilinguisme au canada est
toujours une affaire sensible
il est certain que s'il y en aurait ri
annonce qu'ils vont être sous pression
pour montrer sa bonne volonté avec
bouali est professeur titulaire au
campus francophone saint-jean de
l'université de l'alberta dans l'ouest
canadien et il est spécialiste da droite
et de la politique canadienne premier
ministre chef des conservateurs qui
avait chaque fois qu'il le pouvait pas
lorsqu'il prenait la parole publiquement
parlé en français donc il avait commis
deux
l'idée que l'identité nationale
canadienne était aussi une identité
nationale bilingue parce que des
francophones
on faisait plein à partiquement on peut
toujours trouver qu'il y en avait pas
passé mais au moins au niveau de la
représentation il avait mis ce de l'a 20
est donc un chef wind chef des
conservateurs qui disent on ne serait
pas bilingue les freins tente qu'il y
aurait une régression du côté des
conservateurs qui lors nombre la course
la direction ne pourrai pour rennes 2
ports et ou si l'on est négatif mais
dont seulement lorsque viendra le temps
de faire campagne au québec c'est pour
une chose qui ne parle pas français
aurait beaucoup de difficultés à passer
auprès des francophones au québec mais
les francophones partout au pays
il y a plusieurs jours le député
conservateur fédéral gérard deltell a
servi un avertissement aux aspirants
chefs du parti conservateur du canada
maîtriser les deux langues officielles
au plus vite il ajouté on peut potes de
mes premiers ministres du canada sic on
ne respecte pas le quart de la
population qui parlent français
l'estiment question de respect pour la
réalité canadienne
ça fait cinquante ans que notre pays est
un pays pilote donc tous les gens qui
aspire à devenir premier ministre
aujourd'hui son d'une génération d'un
pays bilingue
donc ils ont grandi son talent à l'école
ou à l'université
et il savait que le canada était
bilingue s'il avait l'aspiration de
devenir le chef de netto beeline il te
doivent être longue
cette dispute dans l'iran des
consommateurs etc est aussi sur fond de
sondages commandés par le gouvernement
fédéral et qui révèle que les trois
quarts des francophones au pays estime
que le français est menacé alors que
seulement le tiers des anglophones ont
cette impression
philippe orfali et reporter au quotidien
le devoir et spécialiste des questions
linguistiques depuis à peu près dix
véhicules
depuis les années 60 à peu près tous les
une candeur ou tous les chefs des partis
majeurs étaient entendus à gouverner le
pays par la suite avait acheté c'était
très haute main il tenait de premier
plan que vous êtes un consommateur en
viennent à tourner le dos à l'électorat
français en ne choisissant pas de le
doute concernant l'importance réelle du
bilinguisme au canada est alimentée non
seulement par une course par exemple la
chefferie du parti conservateur ces
jours ci mais parce qu'a dit par exemple
récemment le premier ministre justin
trudeau sur le mouvement voulant rendre
officiellement la ville d'ottawa
capitale bilingue du pays
à la question de l'animateur qui lui
demandait s'il appuyait l'idée de
désigner ottawa ville bilingue il a
répliqué en demandant sourire en coin et
moqueur si la ville de gatineau voisine
de la capitale la canadienne mais qui se
trouve au québec serait prête elle à en
faire autant
c'est un dossier municipal on est en
train de s que la ville de gatineau
serait ouverte à devenir une ville
bilingue
là on part de la région capitale
nationale et c'est toujours cette
équivalence là moi je préfère et écouter
les élus reprennent les élus locaux par
rapport à ça l'animateur patrice roy de
radio-canada a rétorqué au premier
ministre que la ville de gatineau n'est
pas elle la capitale du canada pour
annoncer son intention de devenir lui le
prochain premier ministre canadien le 19
janvier jour où sera inaugurée donald
trump président des états unis
un reportage de radio canada
international